What does metastasis to the bone pain feel like?
Well, so it depends. So it depends. If I have metastasis to the spine, I might not really have any pain whatsoever until there is a degree of bone loss that could cause a fracture.
So when I have a fracture from caused from bone loss because of metastasis to the bone that's called a pathological fracture. So it's not a fracture because I fell down the stairs. It's a fracture because it broke because of lack of bone density because of a lytic lesion in the case of metastasis.
So a person may not have any bone pain with metastasis to the bone. A person may have bone pain. If they do have bone pain, it would feel like a deep ache, a deep ache.
Now, if it was a metastasis to the spine and now you have pain because that vertebral body let's say fractured, then that fracture causes a decrease in height of the vertebral body.
And you'll have pinching of the vertebral ferramid where the hole between the two vertebral bodies to opposing vertebral bodies, the hole on each side where the spinal nerve exits from the spine, the ferramid, the hole, the bone holding hole that that nerve exits will be squashed.
So you'll have pinching of the nerve and that will cause pain and that can cause pain wherever that nerve is going so that could would follow that nerve.
So just like if you had a disc that ruptured and ruptured into the vertebral ferramid and pinched the nerve, you'd have pain with your lumbar spine, you'd have pain down your leg.
But it depends on where the fracture, where the boney metastasis is, most boney metastasis you won't have a lot of pain unless there's a fracture.
And you know it's it goes in stages you'll have law it will just instantly have all this loss of bone and have a fracture you'll have a loss of bone over time.
And you know a boney metastasis takes time to develop so you would probably have other signs and symptoms that would lead you to get an x-rayer to get a pet scan because you're still feeling good and your energy is down and fatigue and it just sounds wrong with me, I just don't feel well and I'm losing weight.
And then they do a pet scan and oh yeah metastasis to you know your twelfth thoracic and your first lumbar and your and your twelfth rib of the right well you didn't have any pain in that area but it was other signs and symptoms that you know brought you in to get tested.
And that's why you ended up you don't go into getting the pet scan.